[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back and happy New Year hot ones
fans this is Sean Evans coming at you
and as the saying goes new year new
tears which means we're back with a
fresh season 20 lineup of some of the
most unique tastiest and spiciest hot
sauces on the planet now if you're here
season 20. I can't believe we're still
doing this show I can't believe I said
this out loud season 20 if you've been
along for the ride you know the drill at
this point so I'll spare you the
conjecture I'll spare you the chit chat
but I will let you know if you'd like to
get your hands on the season 20 hot
sauce lineup heatness.com heatness.com
heatness.com to order all right with
that out of the way we kick things off
in the lead off spot after a very
successful debut in Season 19 it's the
orange label back for its sophomore
appearance
it turns out the sweet heat of the
classic chili Maple is the warm hug that
celebrities need to welcome them to the
table before the Scoville Onslaught
truly begins I'm on record as saying
it's the greatest classic that we've
ever made I'm a big sweet heat guy love
the chili Maple some may argue but you
know what let's put the disagreements to
the side for now and move on to one of
the biggest debates in the chicken wing
eating world and that is ranch versus
blue cheese no matter where you fall on
that debate I bet you will be a fan of
our number two sauce and that's the
Banji Ranch from our friends at
shaquanda's it is what it sounds like a
ranch inspired hot sauce and it gets its
smooth creamy texture from an unexpected
ingredient in that ingredient tahini
shout out to shaquanda's shout out to
Vince Staples I'm sure your bottle of
debt Ranch is somewhere in this studio
rotting away into pricelessness we've
held on to it all right two down and on
to number three and Bill
and intimidating label we've ever had in
the front half of the gauntlet
while it may look like a mix between
Cujo and Dr Evil's cat a cadejo is
actually a supernatural spirit that
appears as a dog-shaped creature with
blue eyes when it's calm and red eyes
when it's attacking and this sauce right
here is always an attack mode with its
mix of habanero peppers garlic and black
pepper and then back like she never left
Los Calientes verde in the four spot
it may be the sauce of Summer but it's
just as good as an antidote to the
Winter Chill let's just say if I were in
the market to buy one of these I'd get
this one first not my words the words of
Tom Segura shout out to Tommy buns
alright moving on to the halfway mark in
this honestly it's where things really
start to change
Brooklyn Deli is all about honoring
Indian culinary Traditions through its
hot sauce this sauce right here it's a
tomato Masala base that features India's
famed boot jalokia Peppers the ghost
pepper for the uninitiated a very very
sharp number five all right moving on to
number six our friends over at
torchbearer Cool Guys by the way they
always have the most Bonkers ideas and
this one right here mushroom Mayhem is
no exception
the meatiness of Portobellos and tangy
red wine vinegar combined for a
condiment that eats like a steak sauce
but that macro dose of scovilles
definitely lets you know hey we are in
the back half now baby all right moving
on to number seven angry goat dreams of
calypso
keeping the back half Sizzle going with
a heat-seeking number seven that
channels the Caribbean with a blend of
pineapple mango and bell peppers plus a
mermaid tail smack smack smack to the
face from a potent seven pot Primo Mash
hello darkness my old friend
I always say Over My Dead Body when
anyone talks about taking the bomb out
of the lineup but really it's over your
dead bodies the fans have made it clear
the bomb must stay hot ones it's nothing
without the fans so for yet another
season I humbly sacrifice myself for you
spice Lords but deep down you know I
wouldn't have it any other way alright
moving on to number nine love the name
butterfly bakeries Taco Vibes only
if you want to crank Taco Tuesday to 11
butterfly bakeries Claire George has
created the sauce for you you have lime
juice cumin coriander they bring the
taco Vibes and then you have Carolina
Reapers and ghost pepper that quite
frankly just [ __ ] up the whole interview
that's what this number nine sauce is
there for take everything knock it off
the rails while I ask a question like
what's the seminal fart scene of your
career that's what this moment is all
about and that's what this sauce
delivers and here we go moving on we are
at the summit of Mount Scoville and look
at her she's as beautiful and
breathtaking as she is predictable the
Gold label in the 10 spot
look around and soak in the view smoking
Ed's Infamous Apollo pepper is the
closest most of us will ever come to the
Sun
and I mean that both metaphorically and
literally in terms of pain penetrating
every single part of your body all right
there you have it it's the season 20 hot
ones Gauntlet by now you know the drill
if you want to play at home heatness.com
heatness.com that's heatness.com to pick
up your hot ones season 2010 pack and as
you know when you see the reveal that
means the premiere is right around the
corner and we will be back next week
that's right hot ones returns for season
20 next week and I will see you there
[Music]
thank you thank you
hello darkness my old friend
did you step on my line Stephen
shut up
yeah
all right
be quiet
that I feel like was highly mutable
Anyway by the way Stephen don't don't
beat yourself up he's like I don't give
a [ __ ]
nice
what's going on spice Lords camera guy
Bill here did you miss me I know I sure
missed you we're back in the studio for
hot one season 20 we're filming we're
grinding we're getting you episodes to
stay up to date for all the latest and
greatest hot ones content please like
And subscribe so you can watch all these
great episodes we're working hard on
this is camera guy Bill here saying it's
good to be back for season 20 of hot
ones
foreign
[Music]